[Music]
every little thing you think that's me
every little thing you think that you
need every little thing that's just
feeding your greed oh I bet that you'll
be fine without me
[Music]
hello everybody welcome to the
minimalist podcast where we discuss what
it means to live a meaningful life with
less my name is Joshua fields Millburn
and I am writing the solo at least just
for this intro don't worry Ryan will be
here in a moment
I'm recording this in an Airbnb in Los
Angeles and if you hear some background
noise there's construction going on
right outside the window or in the
bedroom that I'm recording this in so
it's not the usual pristine sounds that
you're used to thanks to podcast Sean
who keeps our podcasts crystal-clear
most of the time but I wanted to record
this intro really quickly so we get this
podcast out to you on time I'm really
excited about this one we recorded this
live podcast in Pittsburgh let me talk
about that real quickly we just finished
up the first wave of the less is now
tour Ryan and I were in Pittsburgh that
was the very first stop and then from
there we went to Burlington Vermont that
was our first time ever in Vermont we
had been to 48 other states and that's
our 49th state don't worry Alaska will
make it to you eventually we don't have
it on the docket yet but it's just
beyond the horizon I'm sure and after a
Burlington we were in Boston and we were
if we finished up that first little wave
in Portland Maine for four just great
events I don't want to overstate it
because I died in joyed it so much Ryan
and I have been giving this in-depth
talk about minimalism and it's rare that
you have four events that you feel
outstanding about after the fact it
always happens that there'll be some
sort of technical difficulty or we're
all mess up something in the speech or
we the Vipers won't be working but the
crowds at every single one of these
events have been engaging and engaged
their questions have been wonderful and
so I just feel really grateful that we
get the opportunity to speak in front of
these folks and in front of all of you
as well but also to answer your
questions and thank you for forking
10 Ewing to give us engaging questions
if you do want to see us on the road
we're hitting the road some more in fact
really soon we're headed over to Spokane
Seattle and Portland Oregon those are
the next three tour stops that we have
and then from there we're going all over
the country will be in Grand Rapids
Madison Chicago Minneapolis San Diego
San Francisco Los Angeles and we'll be
over in the Midwest again Indianapolis
Cincinnati Columbus Cleveland and I
think there's something like 25 other
cities and one cool thing that we're
doing while we're on the road is our
friend Matthew Vella who directed our
documentary minimalism which is
available worldwide now on Netflix by
the way so if you haven't had a chance
to check it out yet you certainly can
and if you want a deeper
behind-the-scenes look by the way you
can go to our youtube channel we just
worked on this six-part miniseries this
web series with Matt D Avella called
making and minimalism and it really
shows you how we went from just having
an idea of wow back in 2013 we want to
create this documentary to bringing that
to fruition taking a three year period
and getting it out in theaters after
filming and how did we film it why did
we film it how do we get the interviews
what were some of our failures and some
of our wins along the way how did we get
it out into theaters how did we get it
on iTunes and and Netflix and and make
it available worldwide for all of you to
see and we just finished up the sixth
episode to that so it's a six-part
series the sixth episode it was just an
interview with me and Ryan and Matt the
Avella matt has been on the road with us
for this first wave of the tour and
he'll be in future waves as well because
we're recording some stuff I can't tell
you what it's for just yet but I'm
really excited to be creating this new
this new creation
that's all I'll leave it at for now
about what we're creating but I'm
excited to get that out there to you in
the meantime you can check out making
minimalism over at our YouTube channel
it's just youtube.com slash the
minimalist and if you want to see us on
tour you can find all 40 something
cities that we're coming to this year
the cities the dates the details over
at the minimalists comm or you can just
go to les is now calm that'll take you
over to our tour page and a few you had
questions about the tickets you go to
the the venue page or or to buy a ticket
and there are two types of tickets
there's general admission which gets you
a ticket into the door and you get to
see the event just like everyone else
and there's also these VIP tickets and
many of you said well what's the
difference what if I buy this VIP ticket
what does that get me well first off VIP
tickets are limited so in many cities
they're they're already sold out but
don't worry if you if you can't get one
it's okay
but VIP ticket access get you access to
the the first two rows the first two
rows of seats in the theater wherever we
are so you get the best seats in the
house basically you also get to be first
in line after the event so during the
event Ryan and I give a talk then we
record a live podcast and after that we
do this this hug line basically where
the hugs are obviously optional they're
also free and transferable so you can
pass them on but we take photos we sign
books and all that fun stuff as well and
if you have a VIP ticket if you're a VIP
ticket holder then you get first access
to that you basically have your own
individual line but then we also will
give you copies of all three of our
books essential minimalism live a
meaningful life and everything that
remains as well as a copy of our
documentary minimalism if you want them
if you don't want them obviously we're
not going to force you to take a
physical item of course that's a that's
against our ethos but whether you buy a
copy of one of our books or we give you
one because you have a VIP ticket we
always encourage people to minimize them
after the fact anyway so once you've
gotten value from it please pass it on
to someone else who can get value from
it it's not gonna do you any good just
sitting on a shelf somewhere and so you
can pass it on to your local library or
a friend or family member just leave it
on a co-workers desk or in a break room
somewhere hopefully someone else will
get value in that thing as opposed to
just holding on to it and by the way if
you're waiting to get your tickets
whether it's VIP or regular I wouldn't
wait the the Pittsburgh event that
you're about to hear it it actually sold
out and strangely I sold out the last
day of the event that is a rare
occurrence usually when they sell out
they sell away in advance for example
last year we did fifteen said
during the documentary tour and I
believe 14 of those ended up selling out
and they often sell out way in advance
so if you're one of those people like
Ryan who waits to the last minute to get
his tickets then you may show up and
find that there are no more tickets at
least in some cities that will
definitely be the case Ryan and I have
been bouncing all around out this month
it's been it's been a very focused month
not busy we've said no to most things so
we can say yes to the most important
things there was in fact a 24 hour
period where we had set foot in all four
time zones because we finished up that
first wave of the tour then we we we
flew back home to Missoula Montana for a
night and then we drove out to Pullman
Washington have any of you ever been to
Pullman Washington before neither had I
well until last week we we got the
opportunity to speak to this group of
college kids and we showed up thinking
there would be a small group of college
kids there and then we were told no
you're actually speaking in a theater
that seats 500 people but we showed up
and it was more like 750 or 800 people
showed up and unfortunately I actually
had to turn some people away and I'm
just really grateful first of all I'm
sorry if you didn't make it if you
didn't get a chance to make it in there
if you're one of those people who got
turned away we'll have to make it up to
you next time had no idea that our
message would resonate so much and and
what an wash at Washington State
University at Pullman Washington but it
did and but I really feel privileged to
have the opportunity to speak to to the
youth it almost sounds cliche but we're
seeing more high school kids we're
seeing more college kids more
Millennials showing up at our event so
we have everything from 11 year olds to
90 year olds who show up at our events
but I feel grateful that we get a chance
to contribute to folks while they're
young so they don't have to make some of
the same mistakes I made throughout my
throughout my 20s pursuing the the
so-called American Dream usually in our
podcast we record a added-value segment
toward the end of the podcast because
we're doing these live events we're not
doing the added-value segment at the
very end but I wanted to give you just a
little bit of added value this week I
mean lost
Angeles right now oh by the way the
reason I'm in Los Angeles is Ryan and I
had a couple of really strong interviews
great conversations with some folks
while we were here we as soon as we
landed here in Los Angeles we drove out
to Topanga Canyon and met with dr.
Christopher Ryan you might know him
because he wrote a book called sex at
dawn and he has a great podcast called
tangentially speaking in the way he
records it he recorded his home in the
canyons sort of in the middle of nowhere
there's no there's no cell phone service
and it's just out in nature so when you
listen to our conversation we had with
him we'll put a link to that and the
show notes by the way if you listen to
this conversation you hear the birds
chirping in the background and I can
just tell you it's one of the best
conversations that I've had in a long
time whether or not there was a mic or
not a mic in front of me it just so
happened that he mics us up for this and
then we just sit around and talk in fact
it doesn't even feel like he's recording
it just feels like you're sitting around
on a back porch having a conversation
with a really smart friend so I hope you
check that out while we were here we
also did a conversation with Adam
Carolla and dr. drew with all of all
people I never thought we'd be on their
show and had a really strong
conversation with them as well I'm told
that we'll be out this Friday we'll put
a link to that at least their show and
in the show notes and you can check that
out this Friday it was a short maybe 20
minute conversation maybe a little bit
longer than that and they were able to
talk about the documentary and the thing
I like best is Adam Carolla shared this
story about his kid opening something
like a hundred and twenty presents on
Christmas and being overwhelmed and just
feeling terrible and he related that to
consumerism and it was a great story I
couldn't do it just this so you'll have
to go listen to that on your own when it
comes out this Friday anyway back to my
added value segment I'm here in Los
Angeles I went to the lack of my
yesterday I've been to the lack what's
the LA County Museum of Art right LACMA
and I've been there a bunch of times but
there's a new exhibit that just that
just came out I think within the last
week or so it's about 9/11 and it's a
Saudi artists interpretation of the post
9/11 times the post 9/11 events in
was evocative I mean it it left left me
with certain feelings that I'm still
trying to reconcile but but it also made
me start asking some questions about
those feelings and I think that's what
really great art does so if you're in
the Los Angeles area you get a chance to
check it out the exhibit at the LACMA
it's just called pause and I'm not gonna
tell you why it's called pause but
you'll you'll figure it out pretty
quickly after you visit it I definitely
encourage you to check it out if you
happen to be in the Los Angeles area
alright Sean I think that's all I have
for now what we'll we'll move on to this
live version of the minimalist podcast
in Pittsburgh I know I really enjoyed
this and I hope you do too
well hello everybody my name is Joshua
fields Millburn and I am Ryan Nicodemus
and together we are the minimalist and
we are live in Pittsburgh hello
Pittsburgh
y'all are awesome thank you so much
so we have a microphone set up here
usually what we do is we take phone
calls but you don't need to call us
right now because we're all here in the
same room right and so if you're
anywhere even way in the back you're
welcome to come on up here ask your
questions we'll get through as many as
we can we we tend to pontificate a
little bit so you can come up here ask
your questions and eventually we'll try
to get to a lightening round as well
someone has to break the ice yet
the microphones right here in case there
we go all right my name is Angie
Gonzalez thank you welcome to Pittsburgh
thank you so I'm a singer and I have
over the years accumulated a lot of
stuff a lot of wardrobe accessories
shoes wigs makeup you name it and since
I discovered you guys I have eliminated
about 90% of it all
thank you however in all of that I have
also discovered thrifting and so I'm I'm
little proud of myself and I've kind of
you know a lot myself to by things as I
see them maybe if I'm looking for a
specific I don't now go to a thrift
store first so I'm minimizing my overall
expense but yet I'm you know slowly you
know filling up that closet again so
what kind of advice you have for someone
like me who's the parents is you know
important when it comes to career yeah
so a few things thank you for your
question first off a few things I'm
gonna recommend first you you're going
to want to figure out what your outcome
is so quite often we will go thrifting
we were just reading the style earlier
today we had a little vent before this
you know 93% of teenage women teenage
females list shopping as their favorite
pastime favorite pastime and so the the
outcome in that is actually the shopping
whereas what you're talking about how is
how can I shift that outcome
so the
it's to clothe myself and look good in
the process right your style is
important to you fashion could be
important to you but instead of the
important thing being the act of
shopping you can turn the act of
shopping into a just the the means to
get to the actual outcome on top of that
I'm a few sort of practical rules as
well is you can find encouraging you to
wear a uniform
right you don't have to have the black
pants in the black shirt but what you
can do is you can say what are my
limitations so has anyone here ever
tried project 333 few people that's
awesome so you can usually tell by the
way who who's done project 333 and I'll
tell you what it is here in a second
because they're often the best dressed
people in the room and so what project
333 is it's our friend Courtney Carver
who Ryan mentioned earlier she started
it you can just go to the websites
project 333 dot org and basically you
just you pick 33 pieces of clothing that
you want to wear over the course of
three months it seems a bit restrictive
at first and that includes everything
shirts pants shoes I guess it probably
doesn't include underwear but real
minimalists don't wear underwear I'm
just kidding Ryan and I share a pair of
underwear gross but but what you can do
is you set up these these sort of
boundaries for you and they allow you to
realize like wait a minute
these 33 pieces of clothes end up being
my favorite clothes you're going to pick
your favorite things if you're limited
to 33 items and what I see may seem a
bit draconian at first you can expand it
beyond them if you want you get to
create your own rules right and so and
you also mentioned that you have a
family of kids oh nice okay so I think
the important thing to notice with with
your kids is they're watching you as
well and and so whatever habits you have
they're gonna pick up and the good
that's actually good news because if you
have good habits especially around
shopping they often pick up those habits
as well now they're gonna pick up habits
elsewhere obviously but the the person
they pick up their most habits from are
gonna be their parents for sure yeah I
think those boundaries are what are
important for me because you know I am
every day I'm like asking myself like
okay what what if I had for a long time
I put usually like probably like a 30 is
60 day time limit on it but like
sometimes I come across up especially
like the junk try still have 1 junk
drawer and it's important to have a junk
drawer like I got just you know it's all
that random stuff and what will happen
is like as it fills up instead of coming
up with a drunk drawer number two I will
I will clean that sucker out and I'll
tell you like I'll find stuff in there
like that's a year old I'm like I even
think I was gonna need this like little
you know extra third USB cable or
whatever it may be but but that's that's
how I stay on the on the best path that
I can stay on is is constantly setting
it's sticking by those those boundaries
there are other things that you can
implement to like so I've got you know
this 3030 rule where I on either side if
tip I mean there's some seasonal stuff
right like my snowboard I'm only gonna
use a few months out of the year so I
wouldn't get rid of that um but for the
majority of the stuff that I don't use
in the and I haven't used in the last 30
days and I'm if I'm honest with myself
like I'm I gonna use this in the next 30
days I can usually kind of filter stuff
out that way pretty well um but it just
have to be thirty thirty for you you can
do ninety ninety that covers pretty much
the whole year Josh and I wrote about
that on our website
um the 20/20 rule have you heard of that
okay so for those who haven't heard of
it essentially well let me tell you Josh
and I got to this 20/20 rule so this was
2011 we were we were going on our first
tour where you know we'd show up and
like we were lucky if there was five
people or six
people who came out to hang out with us
at a coffee shop I couldn't imagine now
if we were just like oh just meet us at
a coffee shop and I don't know maybe
like the owner would be happy we kind of
a bunch of new customers or something
but but but we get to st. Pete Beach
Florida that was the very first city we
thought it was a very kind of you know
apropos place to start because that's
where Josh's mom was permanent kind of
what really led him down the rabbit hole
which then led me down the rabbit hole
and we were only gone for maybe a week
10 days and you know just a few cities
and we open up the trunk and I'm looking
at a trunk like just full of like you
know duffel bags a garment bag never
know when you're gonna need that suit
what if you have like an impromptu
funeral you have to go right exactly
it but that's that's really it though
it's like it was all these things and
I'm like I'm like dude we're don't no
one can see our trunk man like we are
hypocrites so Josh and I we started
talking about it and it was all these
just in case things and at the end of
the day what we decided is we were like
okay we are not gonna hold on to
anything just in case because most of
the just in case items we could replace
within 20 minutes for less than $20 and
that sound
it might sound ridiculous to some at
first because you're thinking like am I
gonna have to spend $20 every other week
I mean that adds up 20 bucks that adds
up and it does like don't get me wrong
but Josh and I we we've been using that
rule since the beginning so six years
and I can count on one hand how many
times both of us have used it combined
and it's it's just really cheap
insurance because most of those just in
case items we really don't need them now
our theory is like this is a rule that
works 99% of the time I'm sure there is
an exception to that rule but for Josh
and I it has it has worked a hundred
percent of the time so just implementing
things like that and it's you know don't
do it all at once
I mean Josh and I
didn't start doing everything at once we
just kind of would implement some rules
and then as we saw other areas that we
needed or wanted to improve on we would
never implement more rules and create
those boundaries so just keep up keep up
the good work keep doing what you're
doing keeping an awesome example for
your daughter that is so cool how are
you doing good thanks for coming here no
thank you
howdy hey guys I'm Vincent nice mean
Vince I have two questions that is okay
yeah first was what was last time either
what do you guys were in a mall um I was
I was I've been there so we live in
Missoula Montana now and the largest
mall in all of Montana is in Missoula
and large is really relative I mean is
it is technically a shopping mall but
man I don't know it's it's been a long
time I'll go there if I need to but I
know I can tell you a story a few years
ago we were back in Cincinnati for a
tour stop and I had some of the cable on
my phone like broke and I needed to
replace it and so the closest the
closest place for me to go was into a
mall it was the the tri-county mall in
Cincinnati Ohio and I walked into this
mall and I remember not making it down
to the end of the first hallway and I
just turned around and said [ __ ] this
I'm out of here
and
and I went somewhere else that was
farther away just because in the irony
of that is Ryan and I used to manage a
bunch of retail stores so I was a
director of operations for 150 retail
stores I spent most of my days in malls
and going to different stores throughout
Ohio Kentucky and Indiana and now I
can't even stand the sight of of going
into one really the last time I was in a
mall
we just went to Chicago for a speaking
gig that we had and like the the hotel
we were staying at it was like right
there on the Michigan mile and yeah it
is so overwhelming I don't I don't get
like too antsy in the malls um
actually was really cold so there was
like a huge mall that's on the Michigan
mile we would cut through to like
because we could stay indoors for like a
like a block and a half or two blocks
going through all these stores and I'll
tell you every time I walk through the
mall and I remember specifically on one
of the routes we go through Nordstrom's
and I remember like Nordstrom's being
such a big deal to me like when I was in
the corporate world and I was I would
just like go there and we spot stuff
that was on sale that was like always
like a size off but it was like a really
nice name-brand and then like that would
just like either I'd wear it I look you
know a little silly or it would like sit
in my closet with a price tag on it for
a while until I you know finally had a
packing party got rid of all that stuff
but uh but yeah I remember too late
going through Nordstrom's and not only
remembering the that manic feeling that
I would get from going through the racks
and looking at different products but I
also remember that feeling I got when I
was checking out and it was always this
feeling of like I don't have this this
money right now I'm putting I'm putting
it on my credit card I wouldn't make
huge thousands of dollars worth of
Commission and by the time I got that
Commission check I had already spent it
and I just remember always just having
that sink
feeling of going into more debt and as
I'm like in this tornado of a rollin I'm
still like
good to see you things I would leave but
yeah I uh I'm not against malls in fact
during our tour one of our tours Josh
and I we gave a talk in the Edmonton
Mall which is like the largest mall in
North America and people were like on
you know on Twitter and email like you
guys are hypocrites I can't believe go
to the mall to give a talk and I'm like
dude where do you want us to go to like
monastery like a monks monastery like
we're gonna they're gonna put us to
shame like we're not you know we'd be
preaching to the choir like work we're
better to go then in the belly of the
beast you know so it was great we had an
awesome turnout and yeah it was a great
event but I'm not I'm not opposed to to
malls I mean I think we have way too
many I mean that case in point is there
they're gonna shut down a ton of malls
over the next couple years I don't know
if you guys have read that article or
not but um but yeah it's uh it's
definitely definitely something that I
avoid as much as I can but sometimes you
know you can we can stay warm in Chicago
for two blocks walking through Lee oh
yeah yet another question was well you
guys are influencing a lot of people
with what you're doing who influenced
you guys on this journey when you
started my influences it really depends
on the people he mentioned first so I
Colin who runs a great blog called Exile
lifestyle and he has a great podcast as
well called let's know things and the
other people he mentioned as well what I
what I really liked about that when he
was the people he was going through is
when I first thought the first person I
was introduced to was Colin Wright and
he was 24 years old like this young cool
entrepreneur and I'm like oh that's who
minimalism is for and I'm like that's I
I respect him and I appreciate what he's
doing but I don't aspire to be the
Peripatetic writer who who do just John
surround the world in perpetuity and so
like
it might not be for me but then I
stumbled farther down the rabbit hole
and I saw liova balsa and he had six
kids right he's a minimalist with
condoms and I'm like wait a minute I
don't want to have six kids either right
and I don't want to travel the world
maybe there's like a spectrum of
minimalism and for me it was really
about like tweeze and ingredients from
each of those people's recipes and apply
it to my own life if you go beyond that
I mean I think you can look back to the
Stoics so like Marcus Aurelius and
Seneca and I heard one clap for Marcus
Aurelius yeah for a second I thought
that was the sound of one hand clapping
that's good that's Buddhism I think it's
like an old Zen Cohen but anyway yeah so
Marcus Aurelius
Epictetus Epictetus was my favorite the
discourses is a great read I mean some
of the the stoic wisdom is a bit too
stoic for me yeah but they are also I
mean you can go farther down a rabbit
hole you can read about ascetics who
believe they should live in pain and
suffering perpetually because that will
help them deal with the pain that's
that's not what minimal is about for me
it's not about deprivation but those are
certainly some of my influences yeah I
mean the Stoics Thoreau
Josh is a he was a huge inspiration all
of you guys really I mean that's why we
do this it's because it does add value
and you know if you were to tell me 6
years ago like oh you're gonna be on a
stage of Pittsburgh in front of like 300
people and you're gonna get some crazy
applause in' when you guys go out on
stage literally gave me chills that was
so awesome
but anyway like i never would have
believed it and you know the fact that i
think this is an important message and
as long as people continue to get value
out of it we're gonna continue to do it
for sure howdy hello my name is Gina and
actually have two quick well two
questions the first one was how was your
break
your coffee fast at 41:21 main yep so
41:25 right 41:21 main yeah yeah that
was a great shop we just went there
today did we post that okay
nice nice 41 21 was a great shot we
found it on like Google and so I
actually I broke it
yes what's today Wednesday today's today
I don't do we record a podcast yesterday
I don't think so
okay I broke out Tuesday whenever that
was and it was awesome
did you get that like coffee buzz like I
got the oh my god I am so awake I tend
to get up really early so it was like
3:00 a.m. 3:30 a.m. and and I made that
coffee and I was I was midday awake yeah
charged now what are your passions aside
from this I mean there was a deer in
headlights what am i passionate about
living for stuff know I'm passionate
about a lot of things I love to
snowboard
I love hi we live in Montana it's hard
not to find a bunch of passions as long
as you go outside like you can't just
hang out in your apartment all day and
in sulk
no I love going up to Glacier and I
don't do a whole lot of camping but I do
love to camp I I really want to start
fly-fishing but I have set that boundary
up where I was like you know what I'm
not I'm not gonna take on any more
hobbies because I already hat have
mountain biking is another one during
the summer like I love the mountain bike
um but I have a mountain bike I got a
snowboard I'm like and it's already hard
to keep up with all that so I have not
gone the fly-fishing around yet because
once you pick up that hobby you're gonna
have so much like tackle and yes there's
so much that goes with it
but no I
I think that's what's cool about what
I've really learned through this journey
too is like there isn't just one passion
that one of us were born with you know I
wasn't born to be a snowboarder Josh
wasn't born to be a writer but those are
things that you know we both have
interest in and and really cultivating
those interests like putting in the work
that's really how you create a passion
it's it's after you put the work into to
do whatever that passion is so you know
I might wake up one day I'm sure I will
eventually all I was gonna say I would
wake up one day like you know 60 and I'm
gonna be like oh man my back hurts way
too bad for me to go snowboarding
anymore but my partner Mariah her father
is just turned 60 this year and he will
still beat me down the hill on on skis
so I will use that as inspiration that
not quit when I'm 60 for me it's
definitely riding I mean I love words
and I like words - there's so many of
them do I got this book the other day
that's called a dictionary you wouldn't
believe it man it's all the words oh my
goodness
no I I really do I mean just the act of
composition you know it's it's one of
the it can be maddening from time to
time like I want to put my head through
a wall but but there is 50% of the time
where it is like absolute payoff like
where Ryan said you have to Drudge
through that drudgery to get to the
other side to get to the real passion I
think too often we confuse excitement
for passion we get excited about an idea
or whatever we say a lot of passionate
about this but then when it gets
difficult we say you know what I must
not be passionate about this writing is
hard yeah of course it is anything worth
doing is difficult but that's why it's
worth doing it's worth working to get to
the other side you get through that
slump that's for the real passion the
real payoff is thank you thank you for
the questions hey guys just have to say
we are kindred spirits I wake up at
about 3 a.m. usually I'm a passionate
writer and my question is very simple
but I'm suspecting the answer is
how do you remind yourself to be mindful
like when you fall off the wagon and you
just get distracted by those pacifiers
like you really want to be a minimalist
but sometimes it's just really hard to
remember hey this is what's important in
my life and not just what feels good
what distractions are you facing I mean
the usual twenty-two-year-old things you
got friends you've got you know social
media all over the place just anything
that keeps me from either writing or
spending time with people yeah so so has
anybody seen we just started this
animated series called simples thank you
so it's this animated series like where
we just took some essays that Ryan and I
wrote and I did a quick voice-over for
them and Elvin Hayes he he drew up this
whole series but the first the first
episode of that is called some day and
the sort of experiment in there is to
make a sort of to-do list let's take a
piece of paper put a line down the
middle right on one side everything that
you want to do some day or something
you're eager to do another thing you
call it is what are your priorities
right and then on the other side of that
that piece of paper write down
everything that you've done in the last
24 hours those are your real priorities
and if that is browsing Facebook or
going to the mall or whatever it may be
there's nothing inherently wrong with
those things but we don't all have the
same resources here we don't have the
same money we don't have the same
backgrounds we don't have the same
education we all have the same 24 hours
in a day and we get to decide how we're
going to divvy that up and even outside
of work you know there's 16 hours a day
or whatever it may be for you the the
point is that we get to decide how we
spend our time and for so long all of
those things on my Sunday list stayed on
that list and eventually I really had to
do with just flipping those I can put
the other stuff off I could put like
scrolling incessantly through facebook
on my someday list and I can put like
going on our eighth tour in seven years
on my two day
and has a lot more to do with the
actions were willing to take every day
are my short-term actions in line with
my long-term values yeah I would
encourage you to just do some
experimenting like like Josh and I we
got rid of internet for a while it's
really really awesome when you don't
have internet cuz like a become more
productive be like you got to get out of
the house I mean we run a blog so figure
that out we had no internet and ran a
blog so so yeah I would just encourage
you to like maybe introduce some stuff
like that in your life right now like
Josh and I we were I don't think we
published a podcast yet comes out next
Tuesday
boiler alert during the podcast we
reported on Tuesday we were talking
about distractions in social media
specifically and we deleted all of our
social media apps now you might be
asking like well how were you guys on
Instagram earlier today use the secret
you find a friend with a phone podcast
Sean and now we've got Jess Williams who
helps us out too but you know they do
have those on there and they'll post the
forest but I'll tell you it makes us it
makes me way more intentional with with
social media specifically because I
don't first up I don't scroll on
Facebook so that's not that was never
really a huge distraction for me because
like as soon as I get on facebook and
I'll like check all my notifications oh
my do try to stay up with those um just
because I feel bad about ignoring people
but then I'll be like you know done
checking my notifications and I'll be
like all right I'm just gonna scroll for
a little bit and now I'm in a fight so
so yeah I would just don't do that all
at once and you know what let's say
you'll see you get rid of internet for
example and after a month it's like you
really feel deprived like there's
something like it was obviously adding
value to bring it back in you know again
minimalism isn't about deprivation Josh
did that with his phone he got rid of
his phone for it was like three months
right it was two months and it was right
after I got rid of it was a few
after I got rid of home internet so I
lived without home internet for five
years and it was a very productive five
years and and I can tell you the first
month that I did that it was so
stressful but then when I got right
before I got rid of TV and then home
rental home internet and then I got rid
the phone for two months and you learn
about a special kind of lonely but then
I discovered this new thing that just
came out of there called books oh my god
you guys heard of these they're amazing
and there's like pages and words it
talked about I love words right and and
and so what I found as I was reading
more and the other cool thing is you
learn a lot about your friends when you
get rid of your phone and I'm not
telling people to like with Ryan we
didn't just delete all of our social
media we just took all of our phone
temporarily because it's like how can I
retrain myself how the pendulums over
here how can I swing it back here and
then figure out a comfortable middle by
doing that and so I think quite often do
it setting up those boundaries as Ryan
said you can go without something for a
while and then focus on what's what's
truly important for you thank you guys
really appreciate it yeah thank you
thank you howdy hi Barry hey Barry
guys first of all thank you so much for
making your first stop Pittsburgh you
really add a lot thanks for showing up
you really add a lot of values so we're
gonna talk a little bit about
sentimental items let's do it so seven
years ago my mom's best friend from
birth my aunt stitched me a beautiful
large quilt in my favorite colors that
contains pictures of me and my friends
from high school all of whom I no longer
am connected with this quilt is so nice
that it was presented to me by my mother
as being mentally on top of my bedspread
to be just for show during my college
years it laid out in my bedroom at home
unused and forgotten about and since
graduating and moving out of my parents
home
it has become another piece of baggage
carried from apartment to apartment the
quilt no longer brings me joy and has
been sitting in my closet folded up out
of sight out of mind for years my
question is what are my options to
minimize this quilt without hurting
anybody's feelings because the photos on
it are so specific to me that it doesn't
make sense to donate it to Goodwill
because I don't see anybody else getting
value from I got to be honest with you
if I came across that in goodwill I
[Music]
[Laughter]
would be like this is awesome thanks for
my totally wood though my short answer
to you is just let it go and and so you
can't control how someone else is going
to feel you you can try to mitigate that
you don't want to do anything mean you
certainly don't want to do anything
egregious to anyone but if if it's
something that is in your way you have
to understand the people who care about
you want to remove any barriers that you
might have and so you have to give
yourself permission to let it go and
it's going to be difficult now you're
right maybe someone a goodwill isn't
gonna want because I would have had the
same feel like you but apparently Ryan
has cool things sensibility and if
there's at least one more person in the
world who probably would feel that way
too
but here's the other question for you is
there something else you could do with
it that would make it not a quilt wait
are you trying to talk her into like
turning it into a hat or something
a bunch of hats we have a friend Robin
Devine she makes hats calm and well she
makes hats well no I guess I guess where
I'm going with that is quite often we'll
have people who have like these boxes
and boxes of photographs their parents
pass down to them and and we always
advocate doing something called a
scanning party but occasionally what
someone will do is they'll take someone
else's photos and turn it into art
somehow and so the question is is there
a creative way for you to repurpose this
and I don't know but there might be and
I think if you were to ask three five of
your friends then you'll find three or
five different creative ways to
repurpose it yeah and really and if I'm
way off base just tell me but like let's
say you went home tonight and like that
quote like spontaneously combusted and
thank God like that's the only thing
that burn in your closet like you
probably would like probably like oh
don't worry about that anymore
it doesn't need to catch fire for you to
not worry about it
thank you we got we got these last four
and then we'll try to do a lightning
round after that wait last five here's
seven okay let's let's do these four and
then anyone who has a lightning round
question you can ask a quick question
we'll give you a tweetable answer to it
okay so come on out we'll give you
tweetable answer howdy what's your name
hi how are you great how are you hi
Marissa they see me Marissa yeah um so I
guess the biggest question I have for
you guys in an indirect manner not
directly related to monetary needs I
guess is you guys have seemed to found
like a huge life purpose through
minimalism and is there any advice that
you would have for everyone in the
audience as to
I guess finding that life purpose and
that life path because you guys seem so
fulfilled through what you do so any
advice that you would have for anyone in
the audience defining that yeah
definitely so a few things one is get
really clear on what your values are so
so if you don't know what your values
are that's really the foundation upon
which everything else is built and I
think for a long time I I paid a lip
service and if you were to ask me what
my values are I would have given you a
few words that didn't really mean much
they were sort of nebulous and and what
I've realized is that I need to know
exactly what my my personal values are
the Ryan and I did a podcast about its
recently episode 69 it's called values
and if you go listen to it it's
basically we talk about our core values
sort of foundational values health
relationships passion growth
contribution and then how do you build
on on top of that all the way up to
imaginary values and I think that's the
problem for most of us as we say we
think something is important or we just
want that ephemeral bit of pleasure and
now if you look at these tech companies
they're not inherently evil but they
have they employ thousands of engineers
to aggregate our eyeballs to either
their add their product or their service
and I mean some of its a bit insidious
and it's all quite pernicious and and
the the problem that we're running into
is it's becoming harder and harder to
fight that off and and so we need to be
equipped with being able to get grounded
back to what our values are right and so
if you don't know what your values are
sit down have an exercise listen to that
podcast episode I think it'll point you
in the right direction but beyond that I
also want you to realize something you
weren't born to be an astronaut you
weren't born to be a yoga instructor you
weren't born to be a very talented
director matthew vel ladies and
gentlemen
[Applause]
if you like our documentary he's the
whole reason it exists but Matt Matt was
not born to be a filmmaker the key was
finding something it aligned with his
values and in his beliefs and his
interests and putting in the work
cultivating that into a passion over a
long period of time and that's actually
good news because you weren't born to do
something and it doesn't mean to be that
all the stars align so that you can do
that thing now there dozens maybe even
hundreds of things that you can be
passionate about and the key is just
picking one right now making sure it
aligns with those values and then
carrying it forward and then if that one
doesn't work out you pick the next one
and you carry it forward you've got to
be willing to put in the hard work
though that was good answer yeah I would
just echo what he said ditto what one
book for you Cal Newport wrote a book
two books actually he wrote two books
one is called so good they can't ignore
you and it's about that topic of
cultivating your passion and he wrote
one recently called deep work and it's
about just really diving in shooing all
of the distractions in your life and
really having focused work it doesn't
have to be as much as you think you know
some of the most focused people in the
world focus on their craft two to three
hours a day and they accomplish amazing
things over the course of a year or two
years or five years yeah I think if I
did add anything I would just say like
when the joy of doing a thing outweighs
the pain and suffering that you have to
go through to do that thing like that is
that that's when I look at him like you
had freaking I do love this it's like
snowboarding I fell on the first like
the first time I went this year and I
don't know if I cracked my ribs when I
didn't get x-ray but like every time I
breathe it hurt and I mean it was it was
miserable and the second time I went my
ribs were still kind of messed up it
hurt a ton and I'm like getting on that
first ski lift and it was like a Montana
tickets are like 30 bucks but the lifts
are super long and super slow and it's
super cold and like we're going we're
going up and I'm just like why do I do
this to myself every year like my ribs
are like it's I'm so cool right now and
then like we got off that lift and I got
to the top of the mountain I'm like oh
yeah that's thank you hey hey guys
my name is Deb I have been following
minimalism for about a couple years
since 2012 I discovered the becoming a
minimalist blog by Joshua cool Becker
he's great great I discovered that I was
in at that time I was working as a
journalist talking about passion and I
spent pretty much most of my life time
either in photography or journalism ha
that didn't work out too well
financially for me so I'm right kind of
going back track now and getting out of
debt so I've been listening to all of
your podcasts you guys have been
traveling with me 40 minutes a day twice
a day for the last three weeks
potentially I've just been really into
you guys and really your values are very
powerful and in line with the the
political podcast oh my god amazing just
really inspiring cuz I'm really uh
that's not exactly the feedback I got
across the board
I live in Trump town so and then I go to
work in like Hillary Ville it's just two
totally different totally different
things but what I question is so right
now I'm actually in the process of
transition I had a house I lost that
house I had to downsize him now
temporary housing and living with my
mother and trying to get out of debt I'm
trying to figure out what stuff to keep
for when I have an apartment so I'm
we're doing them me and my girls got 20
girls with us guys whoever is doing that
minimalism game right now or in the
middle of that almost 15th day but um
working on trying to figure out where
the best things to keep that I might not
eat right this moment but that I might
need in six months or four months or
whenever it is I do decide to move out
on my own so just looking to see maybe
if you could give me some advice on what
might be good to keep for that first off
thanks thank you for it
gratulations on on getting working
toward getting out of that I know it's
it's so overpowering you know I had six
figures worth of debt half a million
dollars if you count my mortgage and I
just felt like trapped I felt stuck and
so congratulations for working toward
that it took me a long time and a lot of
just really scraping by but I can tell
you what I would do if I was in your
situation I can't tell you what to do
but I can certainly tell you what I
would do with all of that stuff I would
look at it and let's say what items if I
didn't have any of these items which of
these individual items would I
repurchase and go shopping amongst your
own stuff and keep only the things that
you would buy again and then that way
you're not trying to cram your old life
into whatever your new space is when you
move into that new space you'll be able
to fit your new life your new debt free
life into that space
let me ask you are you paying for
storage right now no I actually
minimized all my stuff earlier in life
okay cool good yeah cuz at like anyone
out there who is facing this problem and
is paying you know thousand or 2,000
bucks a year in storage like there
there's the there's the leverage for
that um yeah I would yeah I would see if
it would like Josh said if it was me and
I did do this actually um when I when I
left Ohio and we went out to Montana and
the cabin you know in the middle of
nowhere I didn't think I was gonna be
out in Montana for this long um so I had
like a little spot to my like grandma's
garage that I kind of kept stuff in and
when I got back to Ohio it was like six
maybe eight months after we had moved
out to Montana and I'm like there's no
way I'm coming back to Ohio so there
were some like really awesome things
that that I really really loved like
this like antique chair that I had it
was like the first large purchase that I
had ever made when I was 18 years old it
was like 450 bucks and
I had like a nice was like a nice ish
like washer and dryer I had a nice bed
frame bed all the stuff that I felt like
when I come back to Ohio I'm definitely
gonna like use all this stuff and I had
a garage sale
and I was so adamant about like getting
that stuff out of my grandma's garage
I'm not gonna like you know let her keep
burdening that that storage space and
it's just an aside the there was a
statistic we were talking about earlier
today where it's like 25 percent of the
people who have a two-car garage they
can park one car in there zero cars
oh I'm sorry zero cars and then 33
percent can park one car in there yes
yeah so so yeah I didn't want to do that
to my grandma so I had a garage sale and
sold the what actually I knew someone
who needed a washer and dryer so I sold
it to him super cheap like pennies on
the dollar what I paid for it paid for
him um and then an antique chair like
this was the heart this was like the
hardest thing I had to let go of and it
wasn't for any other reason than like
the sentimental attachment I had to it
first big purchase when I had into my
home every every time I you know would
put that like as my centerpiece in my
home people will come over there like
that is an awesome chair I'm like yeah I
know it is an awesome chair like I
picked this out specifically um some but
some a couple came by
during the garage sale and they are for
me 45 bucks for it and I'm like I'm like
can you give me like 65 they're like now
man like and I could just tell like they
just you know they weren't really having
it but they're really excited about it
that is that you know have more than 45
bucks
and I'm like you know what I'm gonna
give it to you guys for 45 bucks and
they were so hot like they were like
they just got the buy of a century and I
knew he's like I know exactly where this
is gonna go like I'm so excited it's
like we've been looking for a chair for
months
and yeah like I was really happy to give
the give that to someone else who could
use it but I guess I'm just encouraging
you if there is stuff that you're
holding on to because you feel like oh
we have to buy that again you know be
honest with yourself are you gonna have
to buy it again and then when you sell
it just think about like every single
penny you get you could you get to put
towards that debt it's gonna get you
closer to getting out of mom's house
which is your goal ultimately right
thanks so much for the question thank
you guys well do one more regular round
question before we move on to the the
tweetable questions with tweetable
answers howdy
what's your name oh oh you Jeff yes this
is a guy buying all the drinks oh I'm
Ryan
Joshua Joshua I had a question for Josh
about his story
I wanted to ask man you know I get it
that your your mom passed away right and
that was really hard for you yeah and I
get it you know so how'd it be in a
minute
minimalist say that five times fast Jeff
right but I mean you know my dad had
some stuff too you know yeah and I hold
on to his things and I really did I hear
I hold him very near and dear to my
heart he didn't have as much as you your
mother might have had he has some things
so you know and I'm trying to really
find a happy spot in life right now how
did that help you grieve Bingaman a
minimalist yeah that helped you grieve
how does it help you cope with your life
you know I mean I get it I get I get rid
of my stuff on a daily basis and I have
not many things I accept the simple
things in life I don't ask for much I
don't ask for anything from anybody you
know and I have not much but I need help
reeving sure you know in and I'm always
throwing away things because I'm like
you know what I don't need this stuff I
don't need it and you know if I get rid
of it I won't have as much I don't have
as much to worry about
so it's like you know what kind of stuff
did your dad leave by I'm just just
little trinkets do you use some of it
though yeah man and you know and I used
a lot of life lessons - my dad was a
really cool guy you know I used a lot of
lifeless I can't a lot and he was almost
a minimalist to begin with I guess I
guess that's a new word it's hard for me
to say because I don't I don't know you
I don't know we can't a lot you know we
were we lived outside a lot you know
sure but um we just didn't have a lot
but I'm just my question you is how did
it help you cope yeah you know like
giving away your mom's stuff you know
you looked at this things and these are
things that your mom's seen in you right
you know me I have a daughter and it's
like I see things in her and I keep
little drawings that she's had since she
was two years old right you know she's
she's almost do me seven actually I'm
sorry I'm yeah I was gonna check that
stack
[Laughter]
you know I mean I keep these things and
I'm hold on to them and she's gonna be
this the person sitting up her on stage
yeah say my dad kept the stuff since I
was 2 right you know how do you cope
with I mean that so how does the help
you cope we have a lot of people coming
to our events now who I mean it's been
nice as the documentary came out we have
a lot of high school kids and college
age kids that they come to our events
but then we had I mean there was
actually one very brief scene a
documentary in San Diego 93 year old
woman was at the event and she was
talking about how she wanted to get rid
of the stuff so her kids didn't have to
and grandkids and great-grandkids didn't
have to deal with it and that letting go
was also freeing not just for her but
for the other people in her life it was
proactive sort of letting go and so for
me I'll tell you this I don't think I
could have as quickly lamented the idea
of my mother's passing I don't think I
would have been able to actually deal
with it if I wouldn't have dealt with
her stuff because I know what my plan
was
I really did call and get the u-haul I
got this largest storage locker they had
I'm gonna drive that big truck back up
to Ohio put it all in that big box just
in case do you know why I was gonna do
that though so I didn't have to deal
with it
and because I didn't have to deal with
that I didn't have to deal with mom's
death she was gone but her stuff wasn't
and so it took me letting go of the
stuff the excess stuff in particular to
let go of her life she's no longer here
but then of course I remembered that the
memories aren't in those things so it
was nice that I was able to take photos
of many her things I still have a lot of
her photos scanned if you use digital
picture frames you actually get to use
the photos instead of putting them in a
box in your basement and I found for me
that that process allowed me to let go
and I don't think I don't think I could
have
without that I think the one thing I'll
add is you know the this is Josh nice
recipe and we have different recipes
yeah so you know our hopes is like hey
there's a couple ingredients where
people can kind of you know tweezer own
recipe for their life and what I'll tell
you is like we're not a you know we're
not against I'm not against sentimental
items like I have a beer stein my
grandmother gave me that I put like all
my loose change in and she's 80
she turned 82 this year and like her
health is not well it's not good I have
to I have to like it's it's it's kind of
really gives me a lot of anxiety
thinking about what I know it's gonna
inevitably happen in the next few years
and I'll probably hold on to that Stein
but you know at the end of the day it is
useful so the first thing I would say is
like dude if this stuff that your dad
has if it is useful in a certain way
then you know throwing away a family
heirloom it's not gonna bring you joy at
all I mean it's it's or I should say
throwing away family Andrew doesn't
guarantee that it's gonna bring you joy
so if it's useful then keep it man
people all the time like in the
documentary I don't if you saw that but
people they come up to us all the time I
mentioned where they're like hey man I
got this library that I love I love to
smell my books and I love my books out
to my my friends and they they read them
we talk about them and I just I can't be
minimalist because of my my life my
library books I'm like keep your books
sounds like you get a lot of value out
of it so that's what it comes down to
it's like are you getting value out of
it if it's stressing you out if there's
if there's some anxiety that is being
caused by these trinkets then there
there is a signal going off and you're
in your mind that's saying it's
something something wants to change that
doesn't mean go home and throw
everything out but it certainly is it
certainly is a sign so I would just ask
those those important questions to to to
kind of help hope you work through it
man
thank you so much Jeff it was really
nice to meet you hey chef
oh we're huggers baby I'm gonna I'm
gonna know down everybody well for those
of you at home we'd love to hear what
you have to say so if you have a comment
or tip for anyone that asked a question
so far today you can leave us a message
four oh six two one nine seven eight
three nine or you can send a voice memo
from your phone to podcast at the
minimalists comm it's time for our
hashtag ask the minimalist lightning
round did you all bring your hashtags
perfect so I knew someone in thank you
my name is Jim the documentary I watched
it and you guys have a segment with Dan
Harris and he talks a little bit about
Buddhism and meditation you guys
practice meditation or any of those
principles in your own lives or anything
to keep you in the present so we need we
need to pick the answers Ryan yes next
question you can't tweet that yes no I
I'm not gonna be able to come up with a
tweetable answer on the spot like that's
alright
no no no worries uh I will come up with
a couple sentence answer yes I meditate
every single day even if sometimes it's
for a minute which I was telling we were
on Dan Harris's podcast and he was like
so you don't really follow any rules in
life like I'm like I I don't follow all
the rules no like I met it Asian for
most people was like this 1015 minute I
mean even if it's 60 seconds like I will
just take a minute to breathe and like
to really try and clear my head
and sometimes that meant it will turn
into 50 minutes and that's great on the
plane right here they had like the
headspace some headspace videos like on
the on the entertainment thing on the
airplane and I was totally using that to
to meditate on the way here so yes
it absolutely helps me clear a lot of
mental clutter and there there is a
muscle memory that you get to really how
impulses like I I know that and probably
because I put all these boundaries in
and instilled them into my life but I
think the meditation has certainly
helped to like when I catch myself
walking through the mall in Chicago I'm
sure I can't remember what but I know I
saw something I'm like just gonna go in
there check it out I'm like no you're
not like just and I can catch those
thoughts so tweet that so on the
airplane we flew United over here and I
I kept trying to get them to drag Ryan
off the plane I thought like it came
with your ticket I kept asking them to
[Laughter]
yeah I meditate and I don't have a pity
answer for you I'm sorry but it I find
it's important because oh here we go
here's a pity here's a penny thing for
you for you so our material possessions
are a physical manifestation of what's
going on inside us hashtag lightning
around thank you thank you very much
ma'am essentially and have escaped your
kind of corporate world that you
describe in your previous life how do
you manage your day-to-day is it via
like a calendar on your phone right do
you set priorities bi-weekly basis
things of that nature you go first I'm
gonna try to think of something pithy
my short-term actions must align with my
long-term values every day he's such a
cheater no it's good man um I have three
things that like I have to do every day
it's like exercise of some sort walking
around going to the gym snowboarding I
have to meditate for at least 60 seconds
[Laughter]
what's that right right right
no that and the other thing is is like I
really have to add as much value as
possible into the people around me so if
I don't live up to that then I feel
miserable and really what Josh said is
just a short answer to what I just said
we're just saying a different thank you
hello hello
awesome we're excited too thanks for
coming thanks for coming to Pittsburgh
for your first first part of the tour
okay okay so once you've gotten rid of
all of the stuff the decluttering is
gone your schedule is a little bit
lighter how do you find motivation to go
do those joys in life I mean I'm a
college student sometimes I just need a
nap but at the same time I want to go
out and I want to you know enjoy the
little things in life come to more shows
things of that nature that I'm trying
something Pippi usually have like the
night I would tell all of these who
could come up with a pipiens
answer first but I know you win every
time you want a riff you can just riff
and all oh no I think it's something
like I'm trying to think of a tweetable
answer to say this like it's okay to veg
out but you veg out too much you become
a vegetable you know I was actually
tweetable
did you write that down Sean now we got
a recorder we're good make it a haiku
pass pass at Joshua feels like a minute
boys I'll get back to it I promise
thank you thank you hello maybe get one
I own this girl oh yeah no that's all
right the this may not be a short answer
sorry I once you declutter all of your
material things and maybe you even
declutter some relationships that aren't
good for you like friendships that are
just toxic what do you do or what would
you recommend to people who have
relationships I know this is the other
half of minimalism once you get past all
of that decluttering of things what do
you do or what would you recommend to
people who have toxic relationships in
their life that they must keep like
parents siblings spouses has stuff like
that and they must keep them but they
don't want to spend too much time
focused on that too much you know I
don't know how I've got the petition
sorry I've got the Pippi answer I figure
josh is gonna hate this you can't change
the people around you
but you can change the people around you
well fight so get rid of my parents how
about this how about this about my short
answer is victims become victimizers and
and so the only lever that my long
answer is the only leverage you have
against these people in your life is
your time and your attention and if
you're being held hostage by a mentality
that doesn't align with the person that
you want to be then it's okay to let go
at least for now
yeah I will expound a little bit because
no like don't get rid of your parents
I'm sure they're great people
oh actually this was a question for
everyone else I should just note that my
family is awesome well you tell me how
do you know so I have family members who
I do distance myself from like I'm
totally there for them they call me up
and they're like hey I need 50 bucks for
you know whatever hey I need you to fly
home because mom's sick I mean I would
totally be there and like hands down no
questions asked but I I will spend I
will spend not nearly as much time with
them than when I used to because I used
to feel obligated to do that and I
realized I'm like you know what i'm josh
is you know he's he's like a brother to
me and i mean he's practically family
you know for me it doesn't matter who's
who's whose blood someone has in their
veins as long as they're investing in me
i invest in them thank you thank you
thank you we got three more lightning
rounds here what's up guys thank you I
saw your documentary and I went crazy
and sold and threw away things and my
family got scared
isn't that the weird thing like so if
you start getting rid of stuff it's like
oh [ __ ] he's gonna kill himself
yeah they were like what are you gonna
eat on or sit on or anything anyways my
question is basically just about like
digital clutter and two examples would
be in this kind of new era of streaming
like prior to five years ago I have you
know 100 gigabytes of music you know
albums and now also pictures so I think
like all right Spotify right now I just
listen to it all the time but I got old
sell their music that I haven't Spotify
gonna exist forever like what if the
internet shuts down like you know like I
can listen to it and then pictures I'm
like well do I just keep like dumping
these pictures onto my computer or do I
just upload it onto Instagram forever
and then I have it there and I was like
fighting I'm like man my brain is like
caught between keeping digital stuff or
like keeping it over here and I don't
thoughts on digital clutter there we go
I would say first pass no I'm kidding
I think how to say this pithy well I've
actually I won't because I think it's
gonna take longer for me to think of a
pithy answers and just give the long
answer um you got a deal with the hoard
of clutter digital clutter you have
right now simple is not easy
unfortunately and we confuse simple with
easy a lot so you've got to set the time
aside and handle the hoard that you have
right now if digital clutter and then
you have to curate really really well
moving forward that's I mean that's well
you don't have to do anything that's
what I do that's what I had to go
through and now when I do that picture
dump
I like delete as many in this pictures
as I can before I dump them cuz like
I'll tell you to take four pictures of
one thing you're like wow I need the
best picture I took four pictures so I
could choose the best picture I'm not
gonna put all four of those on my
computer yeah you'll never reach the end
of the Internet so stop trying
it could happen yeah it could again and
then yeah and then when that happens
like records will make another comeback
get rid of things that people have given
you because they think it's a great gift
so every Christmas birthday get
wonderful sweaters for my mom and record
player that I'll probably never use and
I am going through and decluttering and
I'm like wow I get a lot of gifts that
people spend a lot of money on and I
don't want this stuff and then I have
all this other stuff but my parents just
give me because they think it's like I'm
gonna need it someday and it's something
that got on sale and oh you should have
this I'm like what am I doing with all
this stuff how do I stop it from coming
in and be like respectful because my
parents do not understand what I'm doing
right now so at all it's partially my
dad so like he's like I don't understand
why you're getting rid of all your stuff
I'm like I don't need it you know so I'm
just like I need help
but my short answer for you is the only
person's permission you need is your own
I think once you realize that it's
really freeing but the best of it here
here's another pithy thing for you the
the best way to deal with clutter as
before it happens and I think the same
is also true with with gifts set it's
April
right now now's the time to start
talking about Christmas gifts and so
don't wait until it's December 24th to
be like you know what I really don't
want all that stuff to you you're
getting me too late it's already here
and now you're gonna make them feel bad
and here's the other thing instead of
saying no figure out what you can say
yes to don't say no don't get me a gift
say yes
give me an experience give me a
consumable bag of coffee bottle of wine
something I can use something that I'll
actually enjoy so don't say no say yes
to the right thing
if well I should say when when someone
gives you a gift they want to make you
happy if your life would be happier
without that gift I assure you they
would want you to get rid of it yes
thanks thank you all right better be a
good question nice what's your name
Erica hi Erica I'm also a researcher so
along with that I've kind of gotten to
where I am now I'm an expert in learning
from other people's mistakes so it was
kind of I was the youngest of two
siblings and the youngest of all my
friends and family friends so I just
kind of watch everybody else blow it and
then I figure out how to not blow it
based upon what they did so I guess kind
of to wrap it up any minimalist regrets
that you guys have things that you tried
that didn't turn out the way you thought
and maybe some things that you would do
differently to get you to where you are
now well of my picking answered my Pippy
answer yeah yes actually no my pity
answer would be if I died with no
regrets I'd really regret that yes and
my pithy answer has something to do with
here we go
hamsters running around so he's still
there I've been up since 4:00 a.m. which
is 2 a.m. Montana time all right all of
my successes are composed of fragments
of failures okay I'm gonna give you some
like I'm gonna try and give you
something really that I mean Britt
really what Josh and I are saying is
like it's okay to fail but you're a
proactive person I totally appreciate
that I try to be as proactive as much as
possible also the only regret I can
think of
it wasn't even actually I don't even if
that was a regret but you know like Josh
got rid of his cell phone and after two
months he's like shoot I need a phone
I'm good at people are gonna have to
call me but you know even that was an
experiment and it was it was poised to
fail or not you know and it ended up you
know being a failure but man I'm really
looking for like something like a really
awesome life lesson like don't do this
if you know if you're going down this
minimalism path okay I can tell you my
biggest regret in life is so I told that
story earlier but when my mother found
out she had Stage four lung cancer I
spent seven different weeks that with
her that year she was down in Florida I
mean literally she moved down there and
a few months after she did she found out
she was dying and I spent seven weeks in
the corporate world that was I got so
much [ __ ] from my balls and my bosses
balls for spending that much time off
for seven weeks over the course of one
year if I could do that over again I
would have quit my job the day she she
called me and I would have spent the
rest that year with her I occasionally
still have nightmares about it well
waited on a bright note
really brought the mood down million
well we will be out there afterward we
do give out hugs it's not just Jeff that
gets one whoever wants to grab one they
are free and transferable so pick one up
pass it on
we've got some books out there as well
if you if you want to grab one will will
sign it and all that fun stuff if you
didn't bring your wallet don't have
enough money with you we'll buy one for
you so you're welcome to to grab one on
your way out as long as there's enough
yeah the catch is like after you get the
book and you read it you minimize it
afterwards pass it on to someone but
donated to the library yeah yeah for
sure well thanks for being here tonight
Pittsburgh
[Applause]
thank you if you live here tonight with
just one message we hope what's this
love people and use things because the
opposite never works thanks for
listening
[Applause]
[Music]
every little thing you think that's me
every little thing you think that you
need every little thing that's just
feeding your greed oh I bet that you'll
be fine without
[Music]
every little feeling that you got a hand
every little thing that you guys you
gotta reach for and you got a grand oh I
bet that you'll be fine without you
so tear your eyes
[Music]
you
[Music]